- [Narrator] The U.S. economy
lost more than 20.5 million
jobs in April, and 1.4 million
of them were in healthcare,
a sector that has historically
been recession-proof.
This chart shows employment
numbers between 1990 and 2020.
This downturn is the great
recession, where millions
of workers were laid off.
You can see healthcare
jobs continue to rise
during that same period.
And the same can be seen
during other recessions, too.
But this time it's different,
and experts say that
the impact from the coronavirus
crisis could fundamentally
change the healthcare
sector, and a lot of the jobs
lost are not likely to return.
- Healthcare has been among
the most resilient industries
in the economy, and there are
really two reasons for this.
- [Narrator] David Cutler
is an economics professor
at Harvard, and has done a
lot of work understanding
how the medical system
operates, and how it responds
to events like COVID-19.
- One is because people have insurance,
and second is because
people's illness tends not
to vary too much over
expansions and recessions.
Since the pandemic, anything
that's not emergency,
people have cut enormously,
and even many emergencies,
use of care for emergencies
is way, way down.
- [Narrator] To help the
sector cope with the virus,
some healthcare restrictions
were relaxed as part
of the $8.3 billion
coronavirus stimulus package.
That gave a big boost for different parts
of the healthcare industry,
including telemedicine,
that saw one company report a
50% rise in telemed services.
- Now people both in private
insurance and in Medicare
are using telemedicine
a lot, it's hoped that
that can then become a
usual part of practice.
On a scope of practice
front, we enabled a lot
of nurse-practitioners,
medical assistants,
physicians' assistants to do
more, now that we've done that,
we want to be able to keep that.
And the third one which
is really important is,
most physicians' practices
and hospitals get
their money by doing more services.
When people don't go to the doctor,
the providers lose money.
A way out of that is to pay
on a fixed, say per-patient-
per-month basis, and so
that's another change people
would like to see become
a permanent change.
- [Narrator] Another reason
a rebound in healthcare
will be harder than in previous years
is people's financial
exposure to healthcare.
Just looking at the last
recession, and the out-of-pocket
expenses were far less
than what they are today.
- If you're in a big
recession, and you now learn
that you're gonna pay $2500 out-of-pocket
before insurance pays anything,
people may decide they're
happier cutting back,
particularly since they just
had experience cutting back
during the first phase
of the COVID epidemic.
If you then add on top of
that what the potential,
for example, COVID to
come back in late summer
or fall, and by that point,
you really have people
with a very different
outlook for what they want
in the medical system, providers
in very different shape,
and people in a financial
situation where they may not want
to go back to the care
they were receiving.
- [Narrator] Healthcare in
the U.S. continues to be
one of the most debated
issues among lawmakers
and politicians and on a
global level, the U.S. spends
at least 17% of GDP on
healthcare, whereas most other
developed countries spend
50% less, on average.
So while it is critical
for the U.S. economy
that healthcare rebounds
and that it continues
to provide care for those
who regularly need it,
economists are watching
for signs that it emerges
from the pandemic more streamlined.
- So it's really a very bad
idea to have a healthcare
system that's bloated, they pay a lot
and they don't get what they need.
Now the best way to deal
with this is not to just shut
everything off at once and
lay off a ton of people,
but to gradually do things
so that you make that change.
So what I would hope is that
after we make it through
the first part of the
epidemic phase, we come back
in a way that's more
streamlined, so that healthcare
isn't as expensive and
then we help those people
who we're not bringing back to
find other really productive
things that they can do, as well.